okay now I'm not going to talk too much
because I'm listening to my Korean
exposure now my job is to clear the
kitchen or any dishes wash up pots pans
put it in the dishwasher so here we have
our got some grapes going well this is
our compost we finish the thing of milk
here and what else this is my coffee
machine but I can't be talking and
listen to my Korean so I'm going to stop
talking and I will continue clearing the
breakfast table and that's just one way
that if you can take advantage of every
10 minutes 5 minutes 15 minutes it adds
up now I get back to doing my work and I
have a professional camera woman my wife
Carmen is gonna be shooting these videos
and I want to talk about exposure
because I think it's extremely important
right now I listen to these two these
patterns I read them I have my book
handy all the time if I get in five
minutes of listening or I'm sitting here
at my desk and I'm waiting for some
software to work its way through or
whatever I have this handy I can look at
it but when I read or listen what
matters to me is the exposure to
meaningful content I don't worry about
whether I remember the meaning of words
I don't worry about whether it's totally
clear to me I know that if I'm exposing
myself to content that's more or less
meaningful